the inverse of a matrix
trying to get a bigger picture. There we go. Imagine. This is
p
And we want to invert it.
To invert this Matrix. We argument the whole Matrix with
the identity Matrix. Why because we need
to keep track.
of the
elimination process procedures
so this will become your
elimination Matrix
If you remember from Led composition that the L
Matrix.
Is the result of all of the elimination matrices and each
elimination Matrix is going to contain one.
gaussian elimination step
So here, for example, we have how many steps to.
We take the difference of row two and Row 1
plug get into row two.
We check Row one multiplied by three attitude Row three replace
Row three.
So we go through a series of gaussian elimination, and we know
that we have eliminated the Matrix once our original
Matrix looks ends up
in row reduce row Echelon form.
you can see we've gone from
you know this leading one leading one and Lead leading minus
three two getting
once all the across the diagonal
but look what has happened to the original ident Matrix.
And as all of these components, what are these components?
all of the combinations
for eliminating this Matrix this
Is p to the power negative 1?
This is the inversion.
of that
so the Matrix a
can be decomposed into these
three matrices three matrices multiplying again,
and you will get the original Matrix.
in the context of
SVD this
eigenvalue is going to these this Matrix of
eigenvalue is going to be very important.